it is in every nook and cranny of
academia
a lot of people said exactly what you
were saying well this is just some
esoteric nonsense
that a few bozos and the humanities and
the social sciences are doing absolutely
not
right now most of the granting agencies
that fund
you know research in the natural
sciences in physics and chemistry and
biology and the neurosciences
will require the grant applicants
to submit a what i call a die religion
statement die stands for diversity
inclusion and equity
where you literally have to state right
up front
irrespective of what you're saying what
is it that you've done to
you know promote die principles and what
are you going to do if you were to win
the grant
in promoting thy principles
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report quick reminder everyone to
subscribe to our youtube channel and
then re-subscribe when the subscribe
gremlins unsubscribe you
and joining us today is an evolutionary
behavioral scientist
a professor of marketing at concordia
university
and author of the new book the parasitic
mind
how infectious ideas are killing common
sense
god said welcome back to the reuben
report
oh my god it's so good to see you again
i wish it were
being done in person in california but
second best
i wish we were doing this in person i
know that you have a love
of southern california and the sun that
is almost
unrivaled by other human beings one time
we had you in here after you had been in
socal for a few weeks your glow the
color that you can achieve
the bronze it almost blew out our whole
system but you have a very nice tan
right now
well thank you thank you not not bad for
for up in canada so before we do
anything
i had to count beforehand and we were
trying to figure it out this is either
your seventh
or eighth appearance on the reuben
report you are now the most
returning guest of the reuben report
would you say basically in terms of
you've got
a pretty impressive cv your resume is
looking pretty good but where
where does that fall in the scheme i
think if i only put that on my cv i've
already made it so
you're taught all right so look i wanna
i wanna obviously dive into the book
and uh you know you guys sent us the
book a couple weeks ago
and when i was reading it i kept
thinking that
what you're explaining in this book is
what about 20 of us have been
yelling about for the last five years
and a whole bunch of mainstream media
people kept saying oh this is just a
college campus thing this ain't real
you're all overstating it you're
overblowing it
uh and now it's everywhere and some of
these people have actually had mia
culpa's
you're we're seeing some people who who
used to mock us kind of go
oh maybe maybe they were kind of right
about some of this stuff so
let's try it this way for the first
question oh and i can see you're putting
your glasses on so you're ready to
be a learned professor um when did
the ideas when did did you first notice
that these bad ideas were
were creeping into society and then
we'll sort of talk about what the ideas
are
so i call them of course in the book
idea pathogens
and drawing a corollary to how animals
could be parasitized by actual brain
worms
i argue that human beings can be
parasitized by another class of
pathogens
idea pathogens so and hence this is why
it's called the parasitic mind
so i first noticed it when i was a
doctoral student at cornell
i was taking a a course with my eventual
doctoral supervisor
j edward russo who is a mathematical and
cognitive psychologist
and in the course he assigned to his
students
some post-modernist reading that was
absolutely insane now this was published
in the top the most prestigious journal
in the field journal consumer research
you know very high impact factor amongst
the social sciences
and it was complete insanity it was
basically
what is often referred to as a uh you
know
auto auto you know the guy was talking
about his consumatory experience when he
gets a warm erection
thinking about his wife and i'm thinking
this is science
uh well of course it's science because
according to these guys
post-modernism is my truth so if i share
with
with you my truth uh in a dear diary
sense it is just
as valid as quote the scientific method
and so when i was first exposed to this
post-modernism i thought it was
absolute insanity once i became a
professor i got my phd in 1994 became a
professor
i started seeing this post-modernist
thinking throughout
the halls of academia and it was usually
coupled with a rejection of biology
so biology is great in explaining the
behavior of every single species
except human beings so this was the
first instance about
28 30 years ago when i first faced the
insanity
so one of the things i i find
interesting and why i think you're such
a good
communicator about this stuff is a lot
of people think oh
these these bad ideas and identity
politics and all this stuff well this
it only is in the arts and it's only
in you know the sort of superfluous
uh you know classes and things like that
um but because you come from a science
background you've seen these things
infect virtually every level of academia
right it is in
every nook and cranny of academia a lot
of people
said exactly what you were saying well
this is just some esoteric nonsense
that a few bozos and the humanities and
the social sciences are doing
absolutely not right now most of the
granting agencies that fund
you know research in the natural
sciences in physics and chemistry and
biology and the neurosciences
will require the grant applicants
to submit a what i call a die religion
statement die
stands for diversity inclusion and
equity where you literally have to state
right up front irrespective of what
you're saying
what is it that you've done to you know
promote die
principles and what are you going to do
if you were to win the grant
in promoting thy principles now a
colleague of mine
at a fellow university here at sister
university in montreal very prestigious
university
one of my alma maters is a physical
chemist
his grant applicant he's a very very
accomplished physical chemist his grant
application was stopped
at the die statement because they felt
that it wasn't sufficiently adhering to
the die tenants
so those who think that this is just
some esoteric anomalous thing are
absolutely wrong can you go further with
that because i think a lot of people
hear that and they're like oh but the
statement means well and if that helps
more
black or trans or whatever people get
into these fields
that is somehow good but can you explain
why that is actually
antithetical to the type of research
that people like you were trying to do
look the scientific method liberates us
from the shackles of our identity that's
what makes it so wonderful
right
listening to transcendental experience
because
i don't listen to barry white thinking
that i have a certain quota
of black singers that i need to listen
to he transcends whether he's black or
white he gives me goosebumps bumps
because he's
very white so art literature music
the scientific method are the laudable
endeavors that they are precisely
because they remove those shackles of
identity
i come from a world of identity politics
as we've discussed on the show before
when i escaped lebanon so the
fundamental principle on which classical
liberalism as you well know and many of
your viewers know
is a commitment to individual dignity
when you now say
no your individual dignity must be tied
to some tribal identity i don't care how
accomplished you are
as a physicist are you a transgender
person of color and if yes we give you
the grant
what could be a greater cancer to
individual dignity it's grotesque
have you seen how it sort of works its
way up in institutions in terms of
actually destroying the work
so it's not j okay so you hire you know
some of these people not based purely on
skill so
you know people can understand that okay
so now you have a less qualified group
of people at the bottom
but have you seen it sort of really go
up the chain of command until it's
really just wiped out everything
absolutely so in the book i talk about
one effort right now in canadian
universities
which refers to what's called
indigenization of the university
so the indigenization of the university
has many levels so on one level
you have to hire more indigenous people
so that's kind of what we've been
talking about
but this indigenization reflex goes much
much further
there's a professor at the university of
british columbia who was denied tenure
because she hadn't published a
sufficient number of papers
to get tenure she filed a complaint with
the human rights tribunal of
british columbia arguing that she's an
indigenous woman
that in her culture the oral tradition
supersedes the written word therefore by
in by forcing me to have to publish
things in tenure
that is violating my you know my culture
so that's so imagine how insane that is
but there's even a more pernicious
effect of this indigenization
this is this goes to the root of
epistemology philosophy of knowledge
the scientific method is the only game
in town
when we're trying to adjudicate whether
a hypothesis is correct or not
there is no indigenous way of knowing
there is no lebanese jewish way of
knowing
there is no gay way of knowing there is
the scientific method
so once we start we start saying well if
we want to study the
environment we can't only rely on the
scientific method we need to go to this
tribe and
learn from their ancestral bugabooga you
are violating a central tenet of the
scientific method
and it is grotesque so
okay so that gets us to why i love the
title of the book because
the word parasite that that
this this in effect this awful thing has
attached itself
to all of us no matter how clear
thinking you
are on this this is all this is
affecting your life
in a negative way as much as it's
affecting someone who believes in it and
and i what i assume they think is a
positive way
um why the title why the word parasite
so as a evolutionary psychologist
i often look to other animals to draw
comparisons when i'm making some
statement about human cognition
that field is called comparative
psychology comparative in the sense
that you are comparing across species so
that's one of the tools that
evolutionary scientists use when they
are studying the evolution of the human
mind
so as someone who has looked at other
animals i noticed that there was this
incredible field called
neuroparasitology
whereby these parasitologists study how
parasites can enter the host's body but
instead of going for example to your
intestine
a tapeworm goes to your intestine
neuroparasites
seek to infect and alter the circuitry
of a host's
actual brain so the classic example
would be toxoplasma gandhi
that this is the one that many of your
viewers might know it can infect humans
but the classic example is with mice
so a mouse that is infected with
toxoplasma gandhi loses its innate fear
of cats
and it actually becomes sexually
attracted to the cat's urine
not a very good sexual attraction to
have if you're a mouse
because that helps the parasite to
complete its reproductive cycle
there's another type of parasite that
attacks the brains of ungulates
moose elk deer and when they are
infected with this parasite they start
engaging in circling behavior they start
going around and circle
unable to extricate themselves from this
motor pattern so even if the predators
are coming
they won't flee and so i took these
ideas i said well
you know in a sense that's what's
happening to many people who are
parasitized by these bad ideas
instead of going around in circle like
the helpless the hapless moose
it leads us to the abyss of infinite
lunacy
i'll just give you one other quick
example there is
something called the spider wasp the
spider wasp
will parasitize spiders by stinging them
it then takes this much larger spider
into its burrow
it lays an egg and then as the egg
hatches
it eats the spider in vivo that
basically the spider is alive
but zombified well argue that i argue
that political correctness is exactly
akin to the spider wasps thing
it keeps us lulled and it leads us to
the abyss of lunacy
so in a weird way do you admire it
do you admire the genius behind it at a
certain level not the ideas
specifically obviously but it's sort of
when you were talking about that what
was ringing in my head was the movie
alien
and there's this scene where one you
know and you can think of the alien as
the parasite right but but
you know the the uh one of the
scientists they really admire the beauty
of it the ingeniousness of it how
it gets into the body to then reproduce
all of these things do you sort of
admire whoever
sort of really put these ideas together
to send them out into the universe
there's a certain beauty as horrific as
it is right
well i'm glad you mentioned aliens
because it it literally
is a manifestation of invaders of the
body snatchers in this
case of the mind snatchers right that's
exactly what it was doing
and if you if you read the
neuroparasitology literature
it really reads like science fiction
because
there's this incredible evolutionary
dance between the host
and the parasite where the parasite is
trying to always find
ever clever ways as you said admirable
ways
to to dupe the host into its own
reproductive pursuits
so in that nefarious diabolic sense yes
i admire these
incredible mind viruses so do you think
that the host
in this case just the average social
justice warrior walking down the street
or the average person who gets infected
you know through through fake news bad
news whatever it might be
the part that they're getting from this
is somehow like like an
is it an ego stroking that they're
getting or is it a
i understand the way the world really is
and nobody else
like what what is it that the host is
actually getting like is it a comp
it seems to be a replacement for
religion or belief or something like
that
i mean i think it's a it's a combination
of those factors one of the things i
talk about in the book is that
all of these various idea pathogens
share a couple of things in common one
is they
are ways by which we can free ourselves
from the shackles of reality i mean
literally so right so
so militant feminism frees us from the
shackles of biology
post-modernism frees us from the
shackles of universal truths
transactivism you put trans on anything
as a prefix
and it frees you from your genitalia it
frees you from your race i just need to
put trans and that's it right so for
example
i trans self-identified that yesterday i
fasted on yom kippur
i didn't but i self-identified as having
done so
therefore i was a trans yom kippur
faster
you got it so all of these different
idea pathogens
liberate us from the shackles of reality
but they also do something else they all
start
from a noble place and i mean noble not
in the satirical way i often use on
social media
i literally mean it they start off with
a good intention so for example if you
look
at all of the social constructivists
social constructivists are those that
reject biology as being relevant and
explaining human affairs
everything is due to a social
construction well that
pension began as a noble desire
to free the human condition from biology
because
all sorts of really nefarious evil folks
had misused darwinian theory right
the nazis said hey if it's a natural
struggle between the races the jews lost
we're the aryans
hey that's darwinian what's wrong with
killing the jews right uh eugenesis say
the same thing hey if you are gay
we sterilize you so that you don't
reproduce we get your genes out of the
pool
hey it's darwinian well of course it's
got nothing to do with darwinian theory
but the ones who were promulgating these
idea pathogens
were coming from a noble place if we
create a new reality
hopefully we can forestall these bad
things so they start off with noble
causes
freeing us from the shackles of reality
but then of course when you murder the
truth there's always downstream
consequences that are nefarious
and that's what we're seeing today i
can't do one show without saying the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions that's what it always seems
to boil down to
one way or another so do you think that
for for those of us that were on youtube
and podcasts and everything else and and
with the whole
you know intellectual dark web
phenomenon and that whole thing that
largely has sort of disappeared
oddly when when we sort of need it most
do you think in a way
um i want to worry this correctly
do you think we failed in a way that
because we were talking about all of
this stuff a bunch of us were jordan
and peterson obviously and ben shapiro
and the weinstein brothers and
a whole slew of other people it's not
that we weren't discussing these things
and sam harris of course
but but it still all happened it's still
all here we are
do you think we missed something was
there something else that we could have
done that would have been a better
defense against the pathogen
no because i think that to eradicate
these pathogens it's a long-term
game it took 40 50 years of brainwashing
of parasitic infestation in academia
i always say by the way it takes
intellectuals to come up with
the truly dumbest ideas this is why all
these idea pathogens
start within the university ecosystem so
it took 40 50 years before
we ended up with justin trudeau as prime
minister who
basically embodies all of the idea
pathogens that i discuss in the book
so so the fact that the idw came up
was certainly a good thing because you
had some people with large platforms who
were
calling you know alarm you know ringing
the alarm bell
but it really does require the
involvement of
every single individual to truly win
this battle so when i tell people
you know i get millions of emails and so
do you where someone says well i don't
have your platform i'm not the fancy
professor i'm not
dave rubin i'm not joe rogan what can i
do well you can do a lot when someone
when your professor
says something in class that you find is
objectionable challenge them politely
if someone says something on facebook
that you disagree with
challenge them politely in other words
it's trench warfare
it's not just ruben and jordan peterson
and gatsad
who are holding the mantle of you know
killing these idea pathogens
everybody who has a stake in this battle
which is everybody who wants a
commitment to reason
logic science and common sense should be
engaged in the battle the problem is
most people because of cowardice because
they diffuse responsibility on others
don't get engaged and therefore the idea
pathogens keep eating away at us
well that would sort of make you admire
the passion the pathogen in a double
fashion wouldn't it because
it's using their own fear against them
at the same time it's using their
their nobility they think they're doing
something good at some level when
you know and then it's also using fear
to keep them quiet once they wake up to
it
pretty clever exactly right it no it's
it's beautiful right i mean
that's why propagandists are so uh
desired because
uh they know how to construct the
machinery of the meme
so that it can have maximal impact right
so they are virologists of the human
mind
one of my endorsers by the way in the
book is paul offit the reason why i
chose him i mean first he's a great guy
he's a he's a virologist he's a
pediatrician who's developed some
vaccines for
child child you know viruses the reason
why i wanted him to because
in the same way that he combats actual
viruses that go around your body
i'm combating viruses of the human mind
so we're both parasitologists
just dealing with different organs and
different types of pathogens
yeah do you think there's a limit we got
into this a little bit when
uh when you interviewed me on your show
about my book
um do you think there's a limit to how
the human mind can fight this
so one of the things that i've sort of
come around to is that the people that
rely
purely on the enlightenment that just
logic and reason
in and of itself are enough to
coordinate a society that can fight all
these horrible ideas
i i just don't believe it anymore i
think that's why we've seen these ideas
um just infect everything
do you think that logic and reason in
and of itself are enough because i think
we've sort of watched a lot of
a lot of our crew let's say sort of
become
irrelevant in this fight because relying
on logic and reason sometimes isn't
enough
yeah so in chapter two of my book it's
the book is about thinking versus
feeling right
truth versus hurt feelings and the
reason why i set up that dichotomy
is precisely to address in a sense some
of your points which is
it's not so much that these two systems
should be pitted against each other it's
not that we are a thinking animal
or a feeling animal it's that depending
on the condition
we should trigger the right system so
when i'm when i'm when i'm walking down
an alley to take a shortcut to get home
and i see four young men loitering
around
my heart will start pounding i'll start
getting nervous i'm getting a
evolved fear-based response that makes
perfect sense in this case
my affective system has kicked in and it
makes sense that it would do so
on the other hand my affective system
will not help me get an a plus on my
calculus exam
i need to trigger in this case my
cognitive system right
my higher order cognition and so you're
exactly right
you can't always when you're trying to
change hearts and minds
only use reason and logic although in
chapter seven of the book i do
talk about how we can construct
nomological networks
to try to convince people of our
position which we can talk about
but i also use satire i use sarcasm as
you know
that's really getting to your emotional
base system right
so really you have to be someone who's
got a whole toolbox of persuasion
strategies
and you pull out the right tool
depending on the context so it's not
reason or emotions we use the right one
in the right context
right so with that in mind though does
it surprise you that your allies these
days
would would line up more on the right
even though
i know you consider yourself an
old-school liberal and that was sort of
your always home your
your home uh you know i know a little
something about that like
are you surprised or do you think that
this was just the natural extension of
where this was all gonna go
well it it it's it more than surprises
me
it makes me indignant because the word
liberal
has been usurped the word progressive
has been assert
again it's a propagandist game right so
by the way
most people are such cognitive misers
that if you ask them why are you voting
for the liberal party let's say justin
trudeau
they it will literally end at the fact
well i'm liberal that's the liberal
party
i'm not a conservative i mean it's
literally that it's fast and frugal
right
you know the democrats seem progressive
the conservatives seem
like mean and old-fashioned that's the
level of
cognition that people attribute to these
types of decisions
so in that sense i'm not surprised that
i'm now tied to the conservative values
because they're that's really where the
home of true freedom lies today so
i don't care to be in i'm in the tribe
of truth i don't have a home
yeah but do you see a moment i mean i
guess this is what i'm trying because
i'm still
trying to parse this out for myself do
you see a moment
or or a weakness in liberalism so i
think what you're saying is you you see
the weakness as
too much of a reliance on only one piece
of the toolkit right
like you're saying it's just too much
based in logic and reason and that their
toolkit
whether it's about belief or satire or
something else they needed some other
tools something like that
sure and i mean i i think you probably
have seen this that
when they talk about you know who who
does which of the two parties
is better at creating memes viral memes
i mean in the set right who who is
better at comedy right
uh i have i have a section in the book
where i talk about
all sorts of professors incredibly you
know uh
prominent professors who who were all
cancelled because of a misplaced joke i
mean
having a nobel prize does not protect
you
from the ire of the angry humorless ones
right
i i then i refer to a book well
originally a book but then a movie
uh the name of the rose if you remember
the name of the rook did you see it dave
by the way i didn't see it no oh it's an
amazing movie that takes place in i
think in the 11th or 12th century
starring sean connery and a young
christian slater
where a whole bunch of monks are dying
and it turns out that they're dying i
don't want to give it away in case
anybody wants to see it
because one monk is trying to stop them
from reading
a book that has satire and comedy so
satire and comedy
is exactly forbidden whenever a dictator
comes to town
because it is so incredibly powerful to
try to
show the holes in a particular in a
particular ideology that's why i use it
by the way some of our common friends
who are highfalutin and so high bra
in the ivory towers they're actually
fraudulent because
by not using all of the tools that are
at your disposable
at your disposal to try to shape hearts
and minds
you're losing an opportunity so i never
consider myself
above the use of all sorts of tools so
for example you've seen me use the
i don't know if you've seen my hiding
under the table routine yeah
yeah what am i doing there i am i am
mocking the history now this hysteria by
the way
is not something that i'm making up you
could go to my personal page
where these incredibly accomplished
female professors
are literally saying to one another that
they are now going to be afraid to go to
campus
because this new justice might come into
you know might be nominated and
confirmed and therefore it will be too
dangerous for them i mean
do you genuinely believe that i mean are
you this idiotic
so it's frustrating that's why i'm often
so indignant
i i think you probably saw a little bit
of it but i know most of my audience has
seen it when i i did a talk at
university of new hampshire and i'm and
they're screaming at me and heckling me
and the whole thing
and pulling fire alarms and this woman
or a girl a student
starts screaming we could be killed when
we walk
out of here and and i said to her i was
like what what are you talking about i
mean it's new hampshire we're in new
hampshire at 5 00 pm
as if people are just being mowed down
on the streets but what i realized was
the way she yelled it to me
shows how the the parasite to bring it
to this conversation
had it had overridden all of her logic
and reason and and certainly humor was
really off the table
and what was left was just sort of this
screaming lunacy so that
does that also show you the emotional
state like it's all tied into their
emotional state too
exactly the one who is most hysterical
wins
just like i have a section in the book
where i talk about the one who has the
highest victimology score
wins now many people that have probably
come on your show have talked about
you know you know the victimology
currency and what i call victimology
poker
but i may or may not have discussed on a
prior show when i came on
on your platform i offered the actual
psychiatric
explanation for why this
victimology currency has become the most
important metric
by which we adjudicate debates right
it's no longer about here's my argument
please give me yours and let's see who
wins in the battle of ideas it's
who screams louder who's more hysterical
who's the bigger victim
and i argue so 10 years ago in 2010 i
had written
a a scientific paper published in a
medical journal where i was talking
about
munch housing syndrome and much housing
syndrome by proxy which has a syndrome
is where someone feigns a medical
condition so that they can garner
sympathy and empathy
munch housing syndrome by proxy is when
you take someone who's under your care
your biological child your pet
your elderly parent you harm them
willfully
so that you can then garner the empathy
and sympathy by proxy
and so i argued that the hysteria that
we see today the jesse smollette
who is no longer satisfied with making a
million dollars per episode he needs to
be the biggest victim
if he doesn't have a victimology
narrative he hasn't succeeded
well the mechanism by which this
instantiates itself
is through what i call collective munch
housing and collective munch housing
by proxy how do you think
trump possibly understood this it seems
very obvious to me that he
understand you know he may not
understand every every scientific
principle you're laying out there or the
research behind or something
but just that he intuitively understands
and it was what if he was watching this
would say oh yeah that's the stuff i'm
fighting against
i think it's so one of the things that i
teach my students
whether it be the undergraduate mba phd
and i'm trying to explain to them the
biological roots of consumer behavior i
say look
ultimately a good marketer is one who
understands human nature and exactly
what you said
they may not have taken my courses or
read my books to know the scientific
mechanisms behind the principles but
they know
if this product x will work or not as a
function of whether it is congruent with
human nature or not
so what trump has is a good
understanding he's an evolutionary
psychologist
he may be a crass evolutionary
psychologist he may be a vulgar one he
may not use the right vernacular
he may not have a big lexicon but he
certainly understands human nature
and that allows him to win in these
exchanges in ways that the other idiots
don't
do you think there's a uh a way that
they all sort of
need him one of the things i've been
thinking about lately is how if you take
the real
never trump conservatives the people who
he's doing the
stuff that they always wanted done the
conservative stuff he's doing it but but
yeah they don't like his affect and all
that
and then you take the the you know sort
of the disaffected lefties
who can't support him know even if he's
saving the republic in some odd way
uh because they you know he they want to
get they want to go to nice parties
that they both need trump do you think
that there's like actually
a reasoning behind that like they need
to point to somebody else to sort of
inflate their own value
yes i mean i think i i do remember on a
previous show i talked about trump
representing an aesthetic injury right
so
i walk around the world you know
highfalutin language
and sipping and looking at those great
unwashed people
and therefore i expect those around me
to speak with that
you know affectation to to speak with
that vernacular and so on
and then here comes this brash is he
from queens where is he from
queens right yeah yeah yeah so he's from
queens he's
vulgar he's brash he's a guy you know
yes he's wealthy but he seems like he's
got an eight
great eight level you know vocabulary
and
he repudiates all the things that
stroke my ego i'm speaking now as let's
say the highfalutin lefty right
how could this guy ascend to the highest
office when i've made a career
out of repudiating all that he stands
for
if he's successful i am a fraud
therefore i have to put him up on top of
this mountain and
constantly enunciate how much he
disgusts me how much he is an
existential threat i mean the people who
have said that he is an existential
threat for four years
every day they reset the counter today
is when the earth will end
then it's like the doomsday uh cults
right what do they say
on july 7th is when the day ends the
world ends when it doesn't end that day
they change the date that's what the
exit same they forgot to carry the one
that's what usually happens exactly
it's so interesting because as i as i
see this all
unfold and then i do now it's a weird
thing it feels like sci-fi to me but i
see
trump as sort of a bulwark against it i
i also see sort of that they wouldn't
it's almost as if they wouldn't know how
to define themselves i think that's what
you're getting to that if they didn't
have that
thing but yet at the same time to me
that's like
you know the barbarians are at the gate
they're about to push the gate down
there's one guy guarding the door and
you're mocking that guy
it doesn't end well for you probably
didn't
it was it was it douglas murray i i
haven't read his book yet but i i think
he's the one who said something like
you know as the folks are coming to take
over you're worried about their gender
pronouns or whatever
yeah yeah well he said as the barbarians
are at the gate we'll be debating what
gender pronouns
they use exactly sorry i just closed the
the printer
uh so that's exactly it and so look
i i think on a previous show you and i
had discussed what are the some of the
reasons why these
were why a whole bunch of 63 million
people voted for him right
and one of the reasons i gave at the
time which is worth repeating
is that people trump might
fail if you put a whole bunch of
attributes together in other words his
whole package
might be inferior to someone else or not
we can debate that
but if you use for example a
lexicographic rule lexicographic rule
basically says
i look at my most important attribute
and i choose the one that scores the
best of that most important attribute
well if i use that decision rule there's
an endless number of ways by which i can
choose trump
if i care about authenticity well
whether you like his authenticity or not
he's more authentic than
other candidates therefore he would win
if you don't like open borders
and that's the only attribute you care
about he would win
so there is an endless number of
perfectly rational
decision rules that i could apply and it
could come out perfectly rationally for
trump to win
what upsets me about some of our common
friends is that they're not willing to
entertain that conversation
which by the way speaks to an important
thing in my book which is
the fact that you are educated and
intelligent
doesn't serve as an inoculation against
you being parasitized
by idea pathogens because many of our
common friends have phds
and they're accomplished and they've
written great books and guess what
they're some of the
biggest sufferers of ostrich parasitic
syndrome
yeah and that's not to throw anyone
under the bus i mean this is this is
purely just to
i think continue to try to wake people
up to some of this stuff
exactly look some of our common friends
with whom i have
by the way yesterday i put up a thing
where i was defending richard dawkins
for having been the platform at trinity
college dublin
and a whole bunch of people crazy yeah
it's crazy people were sending me angry
emails saying
well why are you defending him you know
how he was going crazy about trump or
how he's going crazy about brexit
the fact that i defend him because of a
universal principle
doesn't imply that i have to agree or
disagree with him on every other issue
and the fact that i have to enunciate
this clearly to you
shows you how parasitized most people
are
20 years ago when you when you were
first teaching about this stuff and
even before that when you were in school
learning about all this did you ever
think that this was that you were going
to be talking about
politics because you spend a lot of time
you know it's not that you're talking
about politics all the time but but
everything is now political and you talk
about politics on twitter and when i
bring you on or you go on other shows
people ask your thoughts on politics are
you or does that seem like it was going
to be the obvious end of all of this
that because of the way it spreads that
it would end up there
no i don't i would be lying if i said i
had the foresight of where my engagement
was going to go
what was clear from my training is i was
studying
psychology of decision making so one of
the things when you study psychology of
decision
making one of the things you do is you
study what's called rational choice
so for example if i prefer car a to car
b and i prefer car b to car c
it has to be that i prefer car a to car
c that's called the transitivity axiom
if i violate this order of preference
that i am being quote
irrational so part of my training and my
doctoral studies
was to study psychology of decision
making or behavioral decision theory
which by the way led to
a nobel prize to one of my professors at
cornell uh
richard thaler and so i come from from a
group of folks
several of whom have won the nobel prize
for demonstrating that economic
decision-making is sometimes faulty
so it was already part of my training to
study
irrational behavior but what was a
surprise to me was that the
irrationality would seep its way from
this very
circumscript you know mathematical axiom
to politics to popular culture so in a
sense i was
trained to look at human irrationality i
just didn't know that i would go into
all these different fields
yeah have you been we've talked about
this a little bit but since i haven't
had you on for
probably maybe it's eight or ten months
or some something around there
maybe even longer but yeah maybe maybe
even longer um
can you just talk a little bit about
what it's like just sort of in the world
of academia right now and just dealing
with other
professors and have you been ostracized
by other people and
and other other kind of headaches
because i think humanizing some of that
stuff you're you know you're not just
some spinning
uh neuron out there you're a human
you've got a family and
people you work with and the rest of it
it's not that this has no cost some
might say a very good looking human but
yes
a gorgeous bronze band
uh so i'll answer this in several ways
so one of the one of the things that
people often tell me well you know
you're protected by 10-year professor
so it doesn't take such courage dr saad
well in 2017
i had to whenever i would go to teach
courses
on campus i had to be accompanied by
security who would then lock the door of
my class
so that if people left the room they'd
have to knock to be let back in
because of the number of death threats i
was getting when i would leave
campus where my wife would come to pick
me up i would literally have something
akin to kind of a deflation from an
anxiety attack
because i didn't know when they were
gonna come at me are the three guys that
are in the elevator with me
are they the ones who are gonna
decapitate me so tenure doesn't protect
you from that
tenure doesn't protect you from all of
the
opportunities i would have had as an
academic other job offers
higher salary i've been denied now
several years in a row a chaired
professorship
which i had held for 10 years and it
would be a cinch for me to
get it renewed but because now how
outspoken
i am and as known as i am now a lot of
people who would be sitting on the
committees to decide whether to give me
the chaired professorship or not
are not very happy with my supposed big
mouth and irreverent attitude
and therefore i don't get that shared
professorship that shared professorship
comes with a lot of money
but do you think it's because they're do
you think it's because they are so
infected that they're against the ideas
or that they
perhaps subtly agree with you i suspect
some people in your department probably
agree with you
but don't want to publicly you know if
they're if they're the ones that vote on
you getting in well now they're screwed
so and that goes to the cowardice thing
that we were talking about earlier
i get that'll i get that a lot you're
absolutely right that the silent
majority i think even within
academia is not on board with this
lunacy but
but again the fact that they are a
minority
doesn't suggest that their diabolical
destruction
is not something to worry about right i
always tell people how many how many
committed zealots did it take to bring
down the twin towers was it 190 000
people no it took 19 people right
so i don't need 9 000
blue haired social justice warriors on
campus to keep the rest of us
be quiet i just need a few of them that
are a lot more vociferous and committed
than the rest of us and then
they will cow us into silence so i think
many professors are exactly what you
said they write to me
thank you so much you're keeping me sane
i don't know how you have the courage to
do this i would have left academia where
not because of you
and then they will often write so what
do you suggest i do
because i'm afraid and then i always
tell them the same thing it sounds harsh
but it really is
it cuts to the truth the the 18 year old
guys who landed on normandy
were not granted safe passage they knew
that 60 70
of them would be mowed down like little
mosquitoes and yet they did it
so that dave rubin and gatsad could sit
here and speak freely today
so whatever it is that you are afraid of
it is a lot less than the guys who
landed on normandy so stop being a
coward
and speak out it's so interesting
because you know i don't come
from the world of academia so i think
one of the things that has
harmed some of our friends ability to
talk about this stuff is
they still want to be liked in those
circles you come from those circles and
you've paid a price i don't
come from those circles so that that
cost is very
low for me but what i find is i'm very
frustrated
by the people right now it's like look
trump is getting critical race theory
out of the federal government that is
incredible
right that's what what everybody what
we've all been talking about identity
politics
it's like he's getting it out of the
federal government and the contractors
the feds can work with he got rid of
title
ix that meant where you know in effect
there was no due process anymore i
thought liberals were for due process
but it's like they can't give him that
credit so my my frustration these days
is so
aimed at at what was my side
that it's it's it's not a comfortable
spot to be in actually
well because because their their
tribalism
supersedes their desire to be truthful
so there is a tension that i discussed
in the parasitic mind between two types
of ethical
systems there there's deontological
ethics
the ontological ethics is absolute
truths it is never
okay to lie that would be a
denthological statement a
consequentialist ethical
position would be if your wife or
husband
asks you do i look fat in those genes
you might lie to protect
their ego therefore it is
consequentialist okay
to lie in this case because it's a
better cause well
a lot of you might just want to get laid
that night as long as we're being
truthful
which is an evolutionary thing so as an
evolutionist
but yeah but when it comes to the truth
and certainly important elements of
truth
then you should never be a
consequentialist so you should never
negate biological realities
in the pursuit of social justice i could
both walk
and chew at the same time i could be for
social justice in the true
sense i am for trans rights i i take
great flag for supporting trans rights
in the middle east which is
which they have a much more difficult
reality than
trans rights on oberlin college right
but
i don't support the because of my
support for trans rights doesn't mean
that a 270 pound guy
who is six foot four who decides that he
is now a woman
can compete with with with biological
women who are half a size
and to say otherwise would make me a
transphobe so i could chew
and walk at the same time yeah
well it seems like it seems that a lot
of people can't can't do that
these days what what do you think it
will take truly to get us
past this that that seems to be the next
step of this conversation okay we we
talked about it for a while
we understand it now the masses see a
problem
but but what is the thing beyond just
the courage part i mean what
what would be a societal way to actually
put some of this stuff behind us
so certainly having sort of a
cataclysmic
you know savior trump come along but
the reality is trump is only is going to
be out either in a few months or in a
few years
so you can't just rely on trump because
he ended critical race theory
then the problem that idea pathogen is
going to go away forever but you
certainly need
some dad i thought he's never i thought
he's never gonna step down and he's
gonna be president until 2064 or
something i could have
i thought exactly exactly uh so so
certainly having someone who was able to
come from the outside
and redress many of these things is
great but i truly think
it's a long game you know
war there has to be involvement for
every so i'll give you an example
my my uh one of my children her her
science teacher
has a blm sign as an avatar so i could
do one of two things at that point i
could say well
forget it or i could write politely
right without being too bombastic
without
engaging all sorts of gadisms you know
cutting satire
i could write to her politely and say
you know is it appropriate
for a science teacher who is educating
my young child
to espouse a particular position what if
we don't agree with this position right
so i can at that point i have a
bifurcation i can either get involved
or not get involved that has to happen
300 million times a day
in every interaction and every exchange
if that happens
the wall of [ __ ] will collapse
quickly if it doesn't
it will be a long drawn-out needless war
so this is why i
implore people get engaged your voice
matters
it's not only up for to dave rubin to
change the course of culture
each of you is important so obviously i
have to ask you
did you ask the teacher to do anything i
know you i know we all pick our spots we
pick our fights what would you do
i haven't i haven't yet because you know
my wife was worried that i might engage
in some sort of
cutting positions that might not be
modulated well enough and that might
cause sort of a retribution of
that so in that particular case i've yet
to do it but i can tell you that my
daughter has often come up to me and
said
daddy the blm is still up so i think
she's kind of almost egging me
to to get involved and in a sense look
by
my children being around me and seeing
the positions that i take
that's one of the ways by which i fight
right so if i do that and you do that
with your children he does that with
this
but by the way the the the cretans are
always trying to introduce the idea
pathogens
ever so earlier so it starts with the
universities then we go to the high
schools
then we go to the elementary because the
best time to reach a mind to make
it as malleable as you can is when it
doesn't have yet the cognitive defenses
to protect itself against the idea
pathogens but by the way she's the one
who made the joke
uh yesterday she was eating something
during kippur and she said well don't
worry daddy i self-identify as
as right so this little child who has
heard my satire was able to construct
that satirical moment i i was told a
story by a friend of mine who has
a five-year-old that in you know the
school year just started
and that one of the parents sent around
a note
uh to the to the other parents in the
class that the boy
biological boy he's a boy at home
but wants to be a girl at school and
they so they want everyone to refer to
him as whatever the
the girl name is the female name at
school but then he goes home and he's a
boy again
and again without this is not mocking
trans people or anything like that but
it's sort of the way it all
spills over so that that everyone else
has to behave
the way you want them to behave but also
could this possibly have come from the
five-year-old i want to be a girl at
school but a boy at home like it doesn't
really sound like that no and listen i
have my younger son who's younger than
my daughter
uh once came up to me and i did a sad
truth clip on it on my channel
where he saw something i can't remember
the exact details but it was something
like
the future is female male toxicity
toxic masculinity and he was sitting
with me watching and he kind of looked
at me and i don't remember his exact
words but he said something like
daddy are are boys really bad it was
really with the innocence of a young
child
and imagine that you are inculcating
to half the world's population known as
boys
this kind of pathological stage right
you're pathologizing masculinity it's
grotesque
we could we could be feminist in the
truest sense of the term and the
christina huff summer sense of the word
without
being pathologizing half of the world
called boys
yeah i know jordan wrote a blurb jordan
peterson wrote a blurb for the book
um that's really what he was hitting on
more than anything else right i mean he
was trying to well i can't say more than
anything else but
in conjunction with many other big
things that
that you can't say to all these boys
you're inherently evil
and now he's been gone for a year and a
half and i think a lot of people are are
lost
without that yeah and i gotta say since
he is a
common friend when i wrote to jordan it
was to for to get him
the to get from him the endorsement for
the book it was literally at the worst
possible time
when he was going through all his stuff
and he writes
right back to me and says you are
literally the first person i'm
responding to
you know since opening my laptop this is
the kind of friendship that matters
right
jordan and i can disagree on some things
we disagree on young we disagree on
but even if we disagree on points a and
b when it comes to going into the
trenches together
you want to have guys who have your back
and at his lowest moment he was willing
to take time so
love the guy dad are you telling me that
academic people could have different
beliefs come to different conclusions
and not try to get each other fired or
kicked out of the university or out of
all the social
clubs incredible isn't it who knew it
it's just bizarre uh what else can can
the average person do
i mean that that to me is where this all
comes together the average guy you're at
i mean
because what it always comes down to
also is the person going forget the
tenured part that you talked about it
whatever and that certain people's
makeup isn't to be combative
but just the person who's going you know
i'm just at whatever my job is you know
i'm a decent hard-working person
i've got kids i've got all these other
responsibilities and for me to
to do that little jump even though i
think most people agree with you most
people heard what you said and they go
well if 300
million people all did it once we really
could change something overnight
but in their own life they just can't do
it are there any other tricks
because this is the question i get all
the time yeah yeah i mean i
so in chapter eight the last chapter i
do have a set of prescriptions like
the chapters called call to action so
i'll give you a few uh one of them
does address the fact that you said oh
some of them are not combative the
reality is
you can't have your values and
principles murdered and raped
without ever being combative if i'm
walking down the street with my wife
and three guys come to gang rape her i
can't say
sorry sorry sweetie i'm not combative so
good luck
right so i i have to and then one of the
prescriptions i have is
activate your inner honey badger now the
reason why again i use this
animal comparison because honey badgers
don't give an
f right honey badgers you can have a
a pride of lines six lines you could go
on on youtube and see those clips
you can have six lines approach a honey
honey badger is the size of
emma may she rest in peace a small a
small dog
and the response will be so ferocious
that the six six lions will look at each
other and go what the hell i don't want
part of this right
so you can't really fight in a war in
this case a war of ideas
without ever triggering your ire without
ever being indignant
so you can't be passive you can't be
castrated so
unfortunately you have to at once once
in a while be kebab so activate your
inner honey badger i also have another
one where i say
be the penalty kicker in soccer there is
if there's a foul inside the the the box
the goalie box there's a penalty kick
from 12 yards away
someone has to step up and take a
penalty kick now it's a very
harrowing experience because the goalie
expects to not be able to save it
if the guy who misses it misses it he's
an [ __ ] he's a loser
so really the one who steps up to take
it is the one who says
i want this coach put the responsibility
on me it's the one that has the the
fortitude to do it
well you have to do that you can't you
know you can't subcontract
and diffuse the responsibility onto
others there is no magic recipe
you all have to get engaged that's the
bottom line
so as a behavioral scientist have you
ever met
anyone who did some of these things
found their honey badger took the
penalty kick the rest of it
anyone who did some of these things and
regretted it long term
oh well that's a good question no i
thought you were going to ask me do you
know anybody other than
myself oh it's a han project no i've got
i've got my short list of people here no
but really because because that's one of
the things i find i always say to people
you know it's
it will there's pain your family members
are going to turn on you friends are
going to turn on you co-workers blah
blah blah but i
i still to this day i personally have
never met anyone that regrets it
no and i i and i tell you i think for i
can answer it for myself the reason why
i never regret it is because
uh at the end of the day i have a very
exacting
code of personal conduct so when i go to
bed at night and i put my head on the
pillow
i have to feel before i go to sleep
otherwise i'll have insomnia
that i've done all that i could however
big or however small
to contribute to the battle if i walked
away tepidly
from a place where i could have
intervened then i will feel like a fraud
so in order to forestall insomnia and
feelings
of being a fraud i have to always be the
honey badger i have to always
walk into the proverbial you know
ideological fight
and i think that once you are driven by
that
passion then you never regret it because
you're living a true life
right i'm very authentic whether you
like me or not
i am who i am and if you don't like it
too bad if you like it great
and therefore i feel good in myself and
so i think most of the people
who rise to that challenge probably have
a similar makeup so they don't regret it
yeah i wanted to ask you something that
was sort of off book topic but
uh but but kind of there too that as we
deal with kovid and watching
you know the spread of misinformation
and we're supposed to wear masks we're
not supposed to wear a mask
lockdowns work they don't work you know
flatten the curve
becomes eight months of don't go out of
your house etc etc
that feels very relevant to the book
actually in terms of the way we take in
information the way our fear centers
operate
and everything else um what do you make
about what's going on generally with all
of this
you know it's so interesting because i
was just having this conversation with
my wife
who went for a walk and i said you know
usually i can
very quickly get a sense of what is the
information that i need to know
so that i can form an opinion and if i
don't know something i have epistemic
humility i'll say you know i don't know
enough about legalization of marijuana
to take a position
and i feel dumbfounded at this point
regarding this covet
because i simply can't i'm getting so
you know it's not like i'm an idiot who
can't synthesize information
but precisely for what you're saying i'm
getting so many mixed signals even if i
try to read the literature
that i can't make sense of what's up
what's down i mean i've i've had on my
own show
you know virus experts who have said
that it is a complete overreaction
that the lockdown has been and these are
very serious virologists these are not
like quacks and so on
so i really the best answer i can give
you is i truly
don't know whether this is one big
conspiracy i don't mean conspiracy in
that covet is not
real and so on but that whether our
reaction to it
has been grossly you know over the top
or not i don't know so
so as a behavioral scientist though like
one of the things that i think all the
time is when i go
you know i'm in socal it's it's warm and
sunny every day everyone looks good and
is in tank tops and
you know basically healthy and you go
into the supermarket and we wear masks
no
now i've noticed people don't look at
each other also because when you can't
see part of someone's face
you sort of don't even see another human
and what i'm worried about
is the the ways it will change our
behavior i i think that could be your
next book
is the way that this the way that the
lockdowns and masks
changed our behavior or or just how
quickly we just accept things
which i suppose has a evolutionary uh
answer yeah i mean dear leader says jump
you say how high
i mean i earlier when i was chatting
with my wife i gave an analogy so if you
look at
you know a healthy environment for a
child to grow up in
they should have consistent parenting in
other words if a child runs to you when
you come home
at night and because he wants to hug you
and you slap him because you've had a
bad day
that's not a very healthy right because
then the child
can't predict statistical regularities
they don't know when you're going to
spank them versus
praise them right so you have to have
consistent parenting
well then i analogize this with the
covered reality that we're facing
most of us are sort of these children
who don't know
when the next edict is going to come so
that i can try to start making sense of
what are the statistical regularities
that i should look for
in order to create a trajectory should i
get married
next year or will it be on lockdown
should i go on vacation next year or
will it be online
and and i think it is one gross sort of
misparenting experiment that we are
facing and the the consequences are
going to be quite nefarious i think
yeah well i can tell you for sure where
i live in california the uh the parents
ain't doing a great job if gavin newsom
is my dad and eric garcetti is my mom
although you got your own problems with
trudeau so we could we could have a
different therapy session about
our our parents but how come you haven't
to continue with the parenting analogy
how come you haven't
uh escaped and ran away from home to
texas or
nashville or wherever the rest of the
good folks are running to
because i want to fight i i believe it's
worth saving and i think there's a
chance and
maybe i'm right maybe i'm wrong but i i
said to david before you know we moved
and
but we stayed in la and i said if i
can't live here i mean if someone like
me
it would be like you being like if
someone like me can't live
in canada i can't live in this country
like the thing has gotten so crazy i
gotta live in canada well
for a certain period of time and i
suppose i know this is a
it's an awful analogy in a certain level
but there were there were many stories
and frank's neighbor you know they they
kept saying you should get out of
germany get out of germany and she said
but we have a nice house and
it'll blow away and i'm not comparing
this to that as much as
some people i think you're you're either
wired to fight a little bit longer and
some
people you aren't but who knows maybe
i'll be moving in with shapiro in
nashville not too long
so you're already a honey badger you've
already activated your inner honey
badger
honey badger from one honey badger to
another all right dad we're going to
link to the book the parasitic mind
right below and you know we could talk
forever so
next time in person my friend you're the
best sir thank you so much for having me
cheers
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our academia playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell